block a with mass M sits on top of Block
B with mass 2m in an elevator the
elevator is moving downward and slowing
down alright when we have this diagram
over here it's moving downward and
slowing down so that means it's
accelerating upwards the magnitude of
the Earth's force of gravity on block a
is f sub G sub a the force magnitude
exerted on block a by block B is f sub a
and the force magnitude exerted on Block
B by block a is f sub B how do the force
magnitudes compare this is fascinating
so pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own all right well
let's just draw a Freebody diagram for
block a so I have a block a right over
here now there's a couple of things we
know we know that this whole system is
moving downward and slowing down it's
and we know that because it says the
elevator is moving downward and slowing
down and BOC a is sitting on Block B is
sitting on the elevator and so if you're
moving downward and slowing down that
means that your net acceleration is
upwards which tells you that your net
force on block a needs to be upwards
which tells you if we have some forces
that are acting upwards the magnitude of
those are going to be larger than the
forces acting downwards so for block a
what are the forces that are acting and
downwards on it well the force of
gravity is acting on block a and that's
that right over there that is its
magnitude is capital F sub G sub a and
what's the upward force acting on block
a well they say the force magnitude
exerted on block a by block B is f sub a
so the magnitude here is F sub a so we
immediately know because we have a net
acceleration upwards remember we're
moving down but we're slowing down so
it's a net acceleration upwards that
immediately tells us that the magnitude
of F sub
a is going to be a greater than the
magnitude of the force of gravity on a
and so we can immediately we can get rid
of some of these choices but they also
are comparing F sub B here so how can we
involve F sub B in this inequality well
the key here is Newton's third law
whatever force B is exerting on a and we
know we call that F sub a or its
magnitude is F sub a a is going to exert
from Newton's third law an equal and
opposite force on B so this is going to
be magnitude the arrows are this arrow
points downward what's going to have the
same magnitude F sub B so the magnitude
of these two forces are the same so
another way to think about it is f sub a
is equal to F sub B by Newton's third
law and since we know that the whole
system is accelerating upwards it moving
downwards but it's slowing down we know
that this thing is going to be greater
than the force of gravity on a and we
see that that is choice B and we're done